action I'll get it in the matrix in the
Navy
look let me know when you're ready are
you ready no laughing I'm a very serious
actor
ready mr. cameraman bless you okay okay
be humorous in this scenario I don't
follow this is very serious stuff we're
not even Lawrence fucking fish eat act
like it I don't know what's ab cowboy
Curtis s shit
don't nobody on the matrix has a sense
of humor so no laughing all right okay
cameraman ready yep you do ready
hmm
I can't look anybody look up you're
wearing sunglasses because you've got
yeah you've got sunglasses on look
through him which is easy to do since he
has no brain
so expose the major see nose
yes I have to see code
oh it's amazing
well now here's the interesting thing
your mother I absolutely loved it I
don't know if you guys will get as much
out of it cuz we lived during that
period the stupid videos in the Gen Xers
film on TV we watch Johnson you don't
see but the one thing I hear is like
yeah I never watch a Holocaust drama
because I didn't live through the
Holocaust would you'll understand okay
we don't look at it nobody I can't I
choose went through man no the one thing
everything really sucks is that they
don't do they can't have the the
speeches yeah that's a shame cuz it's
like such a huge part you know they're
they're copyright right
I can't you I guess by who though my
family I don't know like that's weird
I don't know it's it's weird cuz I mean
it's it I think that's like what what
does oh I know what moving about the guy
it's it's quite a like everything they
read a normal that's weird
oh yeah all right here kid you don't
know it is so did dub over it with your
voice yeah you were really yeah no
that's right even Oprah was good in it
she only had like about five words but
this is Oprah well it was like hey
that's Chicago's media darling you shut
your mouth words I am in the film
haha no she was just like in Pilger
color verbal she gets
colorability you get an own car everyone
who worked in this movie gets a new car
yes
Oprah you're bankrupt Oh oh yes you did
do that actually she threw a party for
the whole cast and crew of the UH she
just went out at first she did just for
hey take a couple middle one of those
like Arabian Sultan's or something that
can have no money it's amazing I wrote
mine yeah by me I'm not complaining
I'd love to be able to do I'll be
invited to an Oprah party yeah why don't
we ever get invited to an Oprah party
yeah maybe because we're always making
fun of Oprah it can't be it I could have
I could have seen it yesterday but I
actually have a the pre-screen there
yeah that's good bro for Birdman how'd
you get that sag oh yeah I see about
those egg Awards right yeah I did vote
what have you six oh well well that sort
is compensating hideous it's a metaphor
this isn't it a metaphor a metaphor
yes but what do you all have against
Paddington Bear this is uh apparently
nothing everybody no I I was just
telling Doug that when my wife and I saw
I forget what movie I think we saw into
the woods and they had it into the woods
yes we saw a trailer for Paddington Bear
and literally like the audience was like
it was awkward laughs and that oh no or
at the end of the trailer when they're
like Paddington like very loosely
audible boos
seeing into the woods are looking at
that it is lightweight very long
diversity a long walks yeah now show me
where you were sitting I'll meet up with
red riding hood well thank you so that
gives you an idea and like my wife and I
turned each other I was like but really
looks like one of the worst films I
could possibly come out this year like
it just looked terrible by the truth the
biggest the biggest joke in it is like
are you pull your wax out with a
toothbrush oh god yeah you took your
wigs with the toothbrush you get in I
could just do that yeah yeah everyone's
just a little bit a million times like
more Macy's I have a dream I have three
more Millennials of listen to it yeah so
I get you junior guy he's like so deep
like a Paul McCartney guy plugging Li
okay but yeah so no and now on red so I
haven't thought about it since then and
Rotten Tomatoes it's sitting at 98
fucking percent that's interesting yeah
and I'm like what how this has to be the
world's worst marketing right look at
that trailer I don't think anybody even
people are disagree I see that it looks
cute would like look at that room and go
oh yeah that is gonna be the best
permute movie of the year interesting so
ah maybe they set the standards low so
when people went and see reminds me of
like well you see us because okay cuz we
got a different makeup I don't do grab
the right one doesn't like she has a
five o'clock shadow now we're seeing too
much marshmallow thing oh I can't tell
if matrix or bad guy from Superman 200
that's rude now say the words
planet Houston Clinic planet planet who
stood now she's way too cheery to be her
sister
micro leave sad even to the children of
Krypton
I'll care here you go sweetie Oh movies
awesome reminds me of Fight Club which
was another one that I didn't want to
see because of the trailer and I'm like
this is one the most amazing movies I've
ever seen my entire life right
huh now if we keep you by Paddington and
Fight Club fight Paddington Oh Mary
he'll fight fair yes Aaron let's make
this happen
you smash hit literally this family
needs this fight fair you know what give
it in the fight like this number one
rule about fight bear you do not talk
about five bear I cannot bear to fight
if this is your first bear you have to
fight I think we've run out of fight
fair Oh
she said bare hands yeah yeah you know
what II was hoping just go back to
camera we need to please the families oh
she's not gonna be in leather in every
episode how any of the viewers maybe she
will
oh my god our views jumped eight hundred
and fifty percent whatever taro popped I
don't know why I don't get it yes yeah
what must be those acting classes she
and if it was ivory we talked about in
the other one but we were really like
because with these outfits always like
can the person move or whatever and
stuff and Tamra you're saying right like
this is really easy to move in right I
mean it's not like too tight it's not -
no it's pretty loose
yeah it's actually like really really
low so it's so we're just weekend yeah
this is why we're too bad yeah it's what
the people in the matrix where every
day's I mean why not it sounds like some
we have 50 shades of grey weather
pajamas yes love it
have you really uncomfortable well we
comfortable I mean it doesn't like you
would sweat I think yeah like there's
it's like wearing a garbage bag this is
your sad you know that's cuz you're the
bomb I don't know this is closer you
have to suck in the cheeks those early
oh yeah there's my favorite in the first
one yes like she gets done sing a line
then just goes into right is amazing
I call it lemon head face is like when
you pop too many lemon heads uses like
you remember warheads yeah too many sour
patch kids are so just yeah okay now big
question uh Malcolm Tamara you to have
not seen dark City right I haven't no
okay well we may open Millennials oh I
have to get a clip because the strangers
the character should plain talk in a
very specific way um the way they talk
is very much like this yes too mad and
they walk like this for their arms I
like this just a little British but not
quite you know now that I'm thinking
about it this was a weird Wow what yeah
no there was a dark cities amazing you
show because it's cool
yes I like dark city close to the end
don't tell anybody
it's a secret to everybody
thirty thousand to use yeah it's a
strangers on
it's the same philosophy it just decided
to tell the story visually without one
stripper down in a wah 60 log and they
talk like a head like while he could
grasp me in his suit
The Strangers dude there's like these
bad guys called strangers and they talk
like them then Kiefer Sutherland please
bull and scientists working with him and
he also talks is Wolcott he has a way of
talking strange cases we'll see I don't
know long okay so what everyone else
talks on huh we said what yeah there oh
man when you do that there you go he's
back okay ah coach okay all right
and Jinna felt all right she's got
anything okay
don't know what I've obsessed with like
having a bellman cater because I gave
the Christmas song why I had the green
thing on I'm like it looks weird he's a
belt
it's like Christmas saintly get me super
your has a belt or something so it's
like maybe you're drunk man eat ice
cream together the belt are the dudes
rug Oh kind of right yeah so yeah so
dude dude please tell me you know the
big I do I was gonna say I'll get to
take that sword away from you and oh
absolutely
or I just knock you why this manga is a
classic anyone who has not seen it you
as some homework watching this right now
yes I'm watching right yeah we know
you're adding words to tell your boss I
quit and go and watch the big without no
no no be like on what grounds your team
Lebowski you like shit
don't jobs not work either that or
you'll see boost on alter but uh
Tamara people were recognizing your gun
yeah yeah is that a metaphor no no no I
wanna know one of my friends uh I don't
even know what them
he's like what does it be um but no one
my friends uh Sammy he's a big Robocop
fan and uh he's like oh that's the like
he named the gun itself the big gun I
don't know what the name of it is BFG
9000 yes what is como oh it's something
with a thousand you never play Doom back
in the day
Oh hmm it's the BFG 9000 it's good for
big fucking gun oh oh that's right when
I was pointing to you probably weren't
even born
probably a sporting community oh no you
were born yet you just probably would
have been mastering like the toilet belt
yeah yeah there we go that classic game
it was four yeah you were four so you've
been learning to tie your shoe yeah god
I'm old old a man see how old the air
I'm 57
oh wow you look great Meryl Streep oh
right what'd you get I always oom din so
touted out of what Oh like we were
talking about I walked through the door
how that happened Jim came back in and I
woke up right behind him right
you like slam the door right I can do
this all day
cuz the first time was so unintentional
he was like try to come in first time
was an accident is okay I could learn to
enjoy it now say thank you for your
cooperation
there it is so there's the guy we use
deadbeat frees deadbeat you're coming
with me
Dead or Alive Robo girl not as
intimidating
freeze open directed robogirl I could
only imagine oh dear
amazing I'd be intensely somebody seen
the original Robocop yeah it was a long
time ago my god you can barely remember
it by okay oh alright
time to record ain't gonna work so we
found out that her makeup is too white
for the new white for the matrix the
Hospice's yeah I didn't think it was
possible but edging all fairness there's
something there like my features is that
I think it stars two white people
everyone like nobody else is white
except for like the bad guy like
everyone else is like it but again still
has to star the two boring white B yeah
the unbelievably - or a boring one Yugi
you gotta have your boring white leads
that is the Hollywood anchor for some
reason cuz rounder every other culture
ethnicity whether you want but you start
to have tall generators Kenan I would
watch Laurence Fishburne leave at moving
the home that would have been amazing
yeah you know I heard that uh actually
Will Smith was up for neo you know I did
that would have been amazed with how
much what Hugh brought to that
performance well he woulda brought he
would have asked yeah he would have
brought more I mean the Bukowski's would
have sucked some life out of him but he
would have brought way more no no
instead of doing the whole whole thing
you just be like you know Morpheus what
you'll be back oh yeah that's why I call
close encounter yeah
Will Smith and Laurence Fishburne how
amazing would that have been I adhere
don't look at me I think of the officer
yeah sister song except except for after
all hey oh I know there's leave that
that was shamans greatest cinematic
accomplishment you mean son into the
life yeah he sucked the life out of Will
Smith almost one of the most charismatic
actors on the planet in some house
Shyamalan like sucked bad out of him
right house keys
Leeson The Matrix films I mean it's like
there's no contraction there they're all
I know I agree you know which is why I
don't into the it's like there's no
don't answer me yeah it's all data
everything very straightforward
everything's a long speech thanks very
philosophical and very dry I mean it's
like they are very similar for another
oh wow yes but running in the rain which
a skis are a lot more visually
interesting than the edges yeah what is
that that's a goodness better what did
you think of will and iRobot
oh he's great he's well this is Will
Smith and iRobot my that's my only
argument though is like you're right
even though if Will Smith was in the
matrix it would have been way better but
it still they probably would have sucked
a little life cuz they did that with
everybody in that movie no no but okay
but it would have been better family a
real spies character actors they have
the ones rng kind of fun in the movie
thing so they've listened it would bring
something unlike Keanu Reeves who just
is like I'm this mannequin doers if you
want no my favorite is Betsy were just
like Will Smith says I'm sorry and I'm
like your Messiah I uh apologize in
mentem whew I'm jaded it's cuz we're
timeless with no Keanu Reeves what he's
just like I'm sorry yeah and you're the
Masai I like know the one you always
have this oh sure yeah yeah I'll try
yeah I'm like no I don't want the savior
of mankind to say oh try this is like
it's like how about I want to go fucking
do this thing I'll bring the game Oh
frustrating it almost to which Trinity
and neo are so terrible yeah it was
weird
poor Laurence Fishbourne fish born fish
burger in the background just sitting
there I'm piloting a ship
all right yo sabes did nothing in the
third one I didn't do jack shit it was
like such a best character in it just
like to to people family you know uh
it's so compare is there way to like the
shades okay is there a way to maybe
diffuse a little bit you see what I mean
it's almost looking to touch two gray
noses okay okay like nothing nothing I
feel like we're a plastic searches the
cave is straw dotted line above the end
I'm bringing the fat tuck this right
scaffold yes unfortunately can't afford
the anesthetic now so
oh yeah that's Burton okay we have asked
from the or rock or bone is Bo sharing
aspirin and drinking rum before yeah oh
that sounds bad hey that's my breakfast
Oh Roman here he is
no Roman aspirin but I call it R aspirin
silence well the I may do the meme
worthy laughs it's okay you know the
crazy thing is is still nowhere near as
creepy or insane as what yeah I'm just
ugh laughing it's I'm not sure that
laugh can be duplicated now that I've
seen you try oh okay
and that there was one I think I not get
my eyes big until I actually start so
just have you guys make sure to make
things less as but that's not hey me
before I forgot sorry
that's for him to know and for you to
review that was a loud jacket all right
full metal
a full metal jacket everywhere okay ba
small yeah
like so so it's like she was wearing
like dark in there
um so wait you were sort of like a
little skin like peels off like that but
there's like yeah I think you got like
just dark okay this or like his skin is
peeling off but it's mostly just kind of
dark under it
hmm so this is how Doug gets his bullet
holes it's how I get my kicks yes on
route 66 this asks for some of the most
obscure things and I need a bullet hole
in my head but with no blood right and
obvious it kind of looks like a mask
that's part of the fun though because
then I have no idea what he's gonna come
up with and half the time it's so much
better than what I came up with
hmm so turns out good at gym just kind
of whips it up on that sort of like that
molding yeah buddy yeah as my skin is
like five shades lighter shit you should
just count like marshmallow fluff and
play Agent Smith there's a state Puft
Marshmallow Man just what a twist
yeah you guys got yeah are you are you
see Newark City right yeah yeah you guys
who dark city Malcolm
yeah the nice thing about after I shoot
this is that I'll file be able to get my
hair cut
Oh cuz it's as soon as I started this
month it was just long it's like shit
these all happen like one after and I
don't think crap yup I'm staying really
still for this cuz I saw that's a
scalpel oh it's a scaffold now there's
no weight on it oh oh confession if you
feel a pinch don't don't worry about it
you're going for authenticity yes just
come on dammit just cards a whole
fictitious I love it but I'm dead I was
one lying that I had a cut from the
matrix review I really miss is like when
Keanu Reeves gets shot at the end like
he just hurts dancer and why you see
such a bad actor he doesn't even know
he's supposed to be dead I think I know
how this works
I fall I'm sure canneries is a very nice
man yeah I just could not stand him as
an act Oh
Aria he was okay in a John awake asking
that you what's okay you know he was
good at villain 10 I mean uh was job
like the new one
yeah what's the one that like but he's
talking about yeah again it's like that
it's like Paddington it's like that edge
of tomorrow movie like it looks awful by
Rose like no it's like really fucking
good yeah so I should check it out I
should give him a chance
yeah would you like him as an actor it's
like I'll tell you when he starts acting
right here I mean just look slamming
let's address exactly yeah it was like
his normal thing but yeah they only
everyone's like don't know it's like
like you say like you get really good
reviews and everything so yeah like I
was going in there you know it's like
okay Keanu Reeves I'm like I'm kind of
enjoying this actually yeah but yeah it
sounded like you said you were gonna go
you're going back home so yeah a little
bit why would you leave this gorgeous
weather I don't get it yeah for
California weather this beautiful gray
melting snow and 36 degrees and the best
is the melted dog poop in the snow
that's oh that's amazing
or the melted the melted geese poop is
really nice oh well that's terrible
Megan with and then sometimes you get
looking at booth yeah so I why she would
want to leave this I don't know we're a
world-class City
I need again yeah
enjoy talking about your eating house
burger well yeah they're talking about
all the different food stuff much more
interesting than Megan Jean yeah all
right now we're gonna try and lighten it
up a touch we think it might be a little
too dark um if that doesn't work them
just go back to this just go fold our
yeah I know people would trip a phobia
must be cringing at this video right now
but I know it is drip drip of Oh via
ears chat no no fear being shot it's
like a just an aversion to surfaces with
porous holes in it oh really and make
people really yeah like like let's say
like the door just hot like
you said this like we would know what it
is like this is a common word no it is
like fried would be able to tell you too
well yeah yeah I think let's see yeah I
think he is I think he does was like
let's say hey that's how you know I mean
let's not the heaven it's a very sad
tragic they don't get me wrong but it's
like good let's not just yeah like trip
of phobia I mean don't say that like
we're not gonna ask what's right right
no like it's it's just like one of those
little obscure things it's not like an
actual like legit medical thing is just
like you know they just get like like a
grossed out cringe kind of feeling you
know my phobia man yeah but the fact
that has that name I mean it sounds
legit right yeah he's like yeah no
that's good we'll do that it's a cool
mirror yeah we got to put that somewhere
sure I try and pull down the makeup
while doing this the whole time
hopefully I'll stay on even when I do
this
Oh Jim that's great we're just talking
about a trip of phobia and how people
might be cringing at that yeah you know
trip of phobia do you know what your
performia is no of course nobody guys I
might be wise financial people with
germophobia must be having problem like
what do you say that's like we know what
it is
ripping ball no I be saying it wrong
come on I'm going to let the fear that a
trip to ball would end up in your
forehead well it's just an aversion to
like services with like pores holes in
it it just like makes people like cringe
oh yes but yo we're literally
re-enacting the exact same conversation
there I mean like word for word oh I
know cars know what
that conversations with people but I
didn't know if holes in it like know it
like any surface that isn't supposed and
like porous holes in it and it does it
like just makes people but it's gonna be
like like million people that come out
of the wood right you like hot river
phobia yes don't you make fun of people
we miss this such a thing does not exist
here you must have imagined it as a rock
like a million people triple foam you're
now gonna be like that was so
insensitive right I might be
mispronounced I hear I have never heard
of it I mean there's a book house
there's a phone right yeah I just didn't
know that I had a name yeah it's not
like a phobia it's just like it just
makes the night yeah yeah anyway I
should be filming you look at this
lovely ensemble yes this is but how's
your stranger voice oh how does it go
again mr. Murdock yes
Oh mr. Murdock yes there you go just say
everything like that slightly British
everything's not going to really
pronounce every and now pronounce every
word there you go
yeah you got it should just keep doing
that yes it's like a Cobra yeah a little
bit yeah
Tamra here gonna be Carmen Sandiego so
the world is business and and how does
your stranger voice coming dr. bet mr.
Murdock yes yes there you go yeah that
bet that's always what I do whenever I
try and do the voice I just say that
well just hit me you've got the roux go
to English but then that's where I was
saying it like without the Hat here take
the hat off you suddenly become a
British nanny would eat soup acalypha
what's this guy
this guy this guy before the show I did
actually totally shaved my head just for
this and my face I had a beard going and
everything better
that's what man do in the winter right I
grew later yeah and then shave him off
in the winter yeah and then Doug calls
you up and like hey would you like to
come out and play a ball dude and I'm
like means I got a shave again doesn't
it it's Association it seems like down
to his shoulders it was like this keep
in mind
four days ago Jim had nothing yeah so
ever so may remember was hang in the
Avatar The Last Airbender review and he
stays happy that this time he has more
lines than whatever no Jim we're gonna
need that I did bring a hat right this
is the right hat right that's exactly
right yeah it says what hand everybody
up down the street if you all look like
you're about to flash somebody you're
you all look like that sign that says
beware predators in your neighborhood
low silhouette side or the neighborhood
watch sign yeah that's what that's the
one yeah is that what it is I don't know
what that was history's because it yeah
they always have just someone with like
a trench coat and a hat and shifty eyes
and stuff yeah right this is look out
for somebody dressed like this somebody
dressed like that it's gonna be causing
trouble in your neighborhood too funny
dude buddies there aren't you ha ha ha
head of a bitch this neighborhood to
everywhere I gamma nation hey saw the
way I dress I don't like it I think this
one yeah now we can take the I believe
that hand had the front of it rolled
down
don't break it just enough is it no just
snap snap how to break a half huh yeah
sink in the second the chief again that
was good yeah you really hit let's show
the camera that you really look like oh
yeah really good yeah that's not any
time you're not talking just half of do
that okay that's someone else yes it
works every time shovels doing it is
Trinity I saw yeah everybody was like a
face yeah carrie-anne moss actually
exact same way in everything I might
note her from bed in memento what else
does she is I've never seen a movie
called phyto item oh okay I know it's
like Leave It to Beaver except about a
boy and his dog
it's about a boy yeah that's lassie Oh
what what no no yes not last so in
second who basically gets a pet zombie
and it's probably what it's like
something the Disney Channel would put
on except instead of a dog it is a
zombie and it is the weirdest frickin
movie so she just had 1940s 1950s
MarySue housewife god I can see that I
will make the cookies for you turns out
she's is off yeah I know doing the
selling lemonade right with the foot up
in the air and everything okay I got see
that just to see any other reaction
outside is also that's SiFi one about
what the hell Kilmer where they went to
Mars Mars and all my tries to kill
cheese a woman up in the ship okay I'm
getting better good white balance off of
this space I'm gonna come back from
Mexico and I'm gonna be just this pasty
earning only the slightest of a cult
following dang it so we dumbed it down
and now on a dialogue people know you
had all those gin and tonics
but it wasn't enough so we replaced
character development with gunfights
weak undertones and something else haha
action but something went wrong
yeah whoa it was a big hit oh damn it
this is really dim it is a big hit damn
it it was a big hit
damn we do lean again and see if you can
actually like turn like that yeah highly
exaggerated yeah it's like super
animated Michelle Jones start justing
with our hats
I am Batman
that was pretty cool and the way you do
remove the matrix yeah I was doing the
fake movie trailers except they freaked
my cat out because I was doing on the
floor
oh she had no idea what I was doing I'm
laying down and pretending to get pulled
into my bathroom and she's just like
sniffing me and I'm like cat get out of
the show you're supposed to be pulling
me into the bathroom your demon cat yeah
for sure
wedding trailer nearly went to the
camera plug it even more explain why did
cuz they are funny oh so uh for my
wedding I ended up filming a series of
fake movie trailers and so was uh each
one was a different genre and each one
is a different stage of the relationship
so the romantic comedy was how we met
the action movie was how I proposed the
horror movie was the honeymoon
and then we did an Avengers like trailer
that we actually use to introduce the
wedding party um during the reception
and so they're all on YouTube you just
search for Muller wedding trailers and
they're on there through either my
youtube channel Trevor Muller or through
my buddy Carl's channel which is three
pixelpro I think it is so yeah how do
you go Muir mu G L Elia a little York or
you can check them out in my website
Trevor a mule
calm or Albert the alien calm boom I'm
just gonna plug it all right look I'll
just put a bunch of tech know what it's
not fun if you see my fake through my
eyebrow okay